i am here with the altar
of sunshine rachel
yes hey cervini's angels hi rich
hi rich cervini he's a producer on our
show
both rachel and i and he's a very
important figure in our life so cheers
to him
and rachel had these made for us so
thank you
again i'm so happy to have it by the way
i just saw john
um pass through yeah he's here hi
jimmy you mean the crew hey drew
you mean i i am the underpaid
sorely underpaid crew hi okay well
that's funny john that you're here
because
we're taking a trip down memory lane
about milestones and memories
in rachel's life and guess what
here's where we're headed next 2005 you
married your husband johnny
i remember that crew
that year that year
john and i got married in uh
tuscany john's first word was more
my first word was vino more wine
you get married in tuscany also that
year
we got isabu we adopted our
doggy that's us 10 years later that was
our 10th
we got remarried on our 10th and isabeu
walked me down the aisle
oh we lost this year uh
just before we lost our home we lost our
dog but
she made it 15 and a half sure
and our show is not just 15 seasons 15
years
everything started the same year the
magazine the show
our marriage the pots the pans the
the brand our foundation
and the dog everything everything
started
in that year that was a big year that's
a big year that's funny because let's go
to the next timeline please
2006 the rachel ratio premieres and
that is the start of everything
everything
just said everything
and that you remember the first day of
the show yeah
i i cut my finger off just like a food
network
every first day at food network you said
emerald seven set on fire well after i
set his set on fire when i had my own
show the first day of my show
i cut my fingertip off this this by the
way she
i was just talking with my hands
and i i hacked the same finger off but i
thought it was good luck
um i should have gone to medical school
because she needs me to sew her
fingertips on like
we just took such an amazing drew the
years
of rachel and john your life
together and isaboo and bella blue
is your new dog is that yes bella blue
blue
is our new dog she's 80 pounds
eight zero she's huge she's not a year
old she's like
10 11 months ish and she's the largest
animal i think we've ever known she's
yeah
she's a small donkey she takes up the
majority of our bed
and we have a big we have an event uh
muttville
is a senior dog oh yeah yeah i remember
they were on the show that sweet
couple and it was the best yeah we're
doing a big
thing online um drew in a couple days
where we're trying to get senior dogs
adopted
and all of the dogs that are adopted we
do
all of their medical take care of their
medical get them up to
up to snuff and woof and we give them a
year's worth of our food
our food uh what is it how much have we
done now
uh over 60 million dollars
and we use money for animals and people
as uh
as fast as we can as fast as we make it
we we give it away
well we're celebrating meat week all
week here on the show
and uh vegetarian and veganism whichever
you like
and i know you have a new treat for dogs
that they'll love
right well yeah well that we
constantly make new things in our line
and to explain to people the quality of
it
i eat it often on on camera just to show
people it's made
with human quality ingredients but the
newest one is
is for big dogs which we we're familiar
with
is very fortuitous because that was a
huge dog
but we make food for every diet of dog
and we make uh pots pans furniture for
every
price tag and every type of cook and you
know we just
like to do things at the lowest
benefit for us possible we take the
smallest amount
for ourselves and we we try we really
use our businesses to generate
what's way more fun philanthropy yeah
and and and making lives better for
everybody and that's been our mission
since day one
and you do in every single way in every
single category
and i just i can't love getting to hang
out with both of you
i love you guys
you